let's go to pablo from albuquerque new
mexico i've never been to new mexico
pablo
hi david can you hear me yes i can
all right great um yeah so um
i'm not sure i really have a question
it's more
a while back you had asked um
why we should keep on bringing up uh
about the deaths of like right-wing
conservatives
and it's sort of touching on that um
wait hold on a second i asked why should
we bring up the deaths of conservatives
uh sorry yes in regards to um covet
deaths okay um
or um
why um
uh pretty much like when all these um
let me see if i can under so you're
saying sometimes an anti-vaccine
right-winger gets coveted and dies
and i said
part of the reason to bring it up is
that it exposes the incredible hypocrisy
and also futility of their perspective
when they confidently say no one needs
to be vaccinated and then they die and
hopefully it'll encourage other people
to get themselves vaccinated is that
more or less what you're talking about
yeah more or less and um
i the reason why
um
i think uh is
um
as you said it uh
just
uh you have to
they're confronted with oh well you know
this um
everybody was saying uh people on the
right conservatives were saying oh you
don't need a vaccine look you'd be fine
you don't have to wear a mask especially
the mask
being
mandate not being required on planes
um it does confront them with their own
um
sort of beliefs um actually uh there's
uh somebody that joe rogan uh
interviewed on his uh podcast megan
phelps rogers who is megan phelps roper
roper yes i've interviewed her as well
okay um i hadn't seen that one i was
actually curious about that but um yes
and uh you know she mentioned how
exactly
being part of the westboro baptist
church uh she had a there's somebody
that kept on confronting her about all
these ideas that she had and it was a
lot harder for her to
once
she was politely confronted with all
these different ideas she sort of had to
come to grips with that a lot of it
didn't make sense to herself yes
absolutely well said thank you pablo
all right thank you david all right yes
let's confront people politely when they
have incorrect ideas let's take a very
quick break we are going to take more
calls in a moment so don't hang up if
you're hanging on to talk to me